massive beschränkungen in nrw wegen des
corona aus buchs wird bei turniers wird
das öffentliche leben in zwei
landkreisen heruntergefahren juristische
niederlage für facebook das netzwerk
muss das umfassende sammeln von
nutzerdaten vorerst stoppen
mangelnde hygiene beim tennis-turnier
von novak djokovic
der organisator und weltranglisten-erste
ist nun selbst positiv auf bewohner
getestet worden
nachrichten des tages heute mit petra
gerster guten abend seien sie willkommen
bei den nachrichten im zdf die vom sport
hat wieder arbeit jemand mitgebracht
haben doch von mir
nach dem massiven corona ausbruch beim
fleischkonzern tönnies hat die
landesregierung von nrw heute die
notbremse gezogen
der kreis gütersloh spricht inzwischen
von knapp 2.000 positiv getesteten
personen
nun wird der alltag von mehr als 640.000
menschen in gütersloh und warendorf
erheblich eingeschränkt denn es gibt
wieder kontakt beschränkungen wie zu
anfang der pandemie im märz draußen
dürfen sich maximal zwei personen aus
unterschiedlichen haushalten treffen
außerdem müssen viele
freizeiteinrichtungen wieder schließen
wie fitnessstudios museen kinos und bars
das gilt für eine woche mindestens aus
gütersloh thomas münten heute abend in
gütersloh
mehrere hundert menschen warten an der
test stelle des kreises um sich
kostenlos auf coronaviren testen zu
lassen
woanders ist das virus kaum noch präsent
hier aber hat das tönnies fleischwerk
die infektionszahlen zu weit nach oben
getrieben
deshalb werden wir jetzt erstmals in
deutschland einen ganzen kreis
zurückführen auf die maßnahmen die vor
wenigen wochen gegolten haben
am nachmittag wurde auch der kreis
warendorf in die einschränkungen
einbezogen
insgesamt 640.000 bürger sie nun
betroffen reaktionen diesen zahlen kann
natürlich die politik nicht vorbei es
wird schwer für die ganzen geschäfte und
so auch wenn sie jetzt noch teilweise
auf haben aber wenn es noch länger
andauert traut sich ja keiner mehr raus
wer sich traut darf noch lange nicht
überall in bayern und mecklenburg
vorpommern wollen urlauber aus den
betroffenen kreisen ablehnen
es sei denn sie verfügen über einen
aktuellen corona test der bestätigt dass
sie eben negativ getestet wurden für
familie gegner aus gütersloh eine
katastrophe schon beim ersten mal
verhinderte der lockdown ihren urlaub
das gefühl dabei ist das ja die ganze
welt reisen darf alle unter um mich
meiner zehn kilometer weiter die tür
überall hinreisen
jetzt sehen wir dann wahrscheinlich noch
wie toll es auf mallorca weiter wo auch
immer wir sitzen dann jetzt schon sagen
ja wir sind jetzt zu hause die maßnahmen
laufen bis zum 30 juni die firma janis
sagte heute schriftlich zu die
leiharbeiter künftig direkt nach
deutschem recht anzustellen
ein interview lehnte clemens tönnies
auch heute wieder ab thomas mieling
gütersloh der unmut in der region über
die firma tönnies ist groß wir wollen
die verantwortlichen denn damit umgehen
das ist wahrscheinlich eine
riesenaufgabe arbeitsminister karl josef
laumann hat ja heute noch mal gesagt man
werde auch baulich darauf achten dass es
in diesem werk künftig diese möglichkeit
der massen ansteckung nicht mehr geben
kann
das erfordert große umbauarbeiten dann
gab es eine mitteilung die sagte dass
alle leiharbeiter künftig fest
angestellt werden sollen direkt bei
tönnies und mit vernünftigen
wohnmöglichkeiten ausgerüstet werden
sollen
nur die leute hier glauben dass
inzwischen nicht mehr denn schon vor
drei jahren gab es genau diesen
beschluss im aufsichtsrat von turniers
eben keine leiharbeiter mehr anzustellen
und passiert ist danach nichts insgesamt
lastet auf dem tönnies fleischwerk und
auf clemens tönnies persönlich gerade in
dieser beziehung richtig chor druck
vielen dank thomas mann in gütersloh
angesichts sehr viel neue infektionen
hat sich heute das robert-koch-institut
an die öffentlichkeit gewandt und zu
weiterer vorsicht aufgerufen
dennoch ist nicht vollständig geklärt
warum es gerade in der fleischbranche zu
diesen hohen fallzahlen gekommen ist
völker tucek berichtet der positive
trend ist plötzlich vorbei am 15 juni
waren es nur noch 220 menschen die sich
im durchschnitt von sieben tagen täglich
mit dem virus ansteckten plötzlich sind
es wieder 580 schuld daran sind
massenhafte erkrankungen auch in fleisch
betrieben wie turniers warum
ausgerechnet die fleischindustrie
das robert-koch-institut hat noch keine
belastbare erklärung geschäft glaubt
aber dass ein feuchtes kühlhaus klima
die verbreitung des virus begünstigt
das eine ist tatsächlich wie sie sagen
die temperatur dort wird gekühlt um das
fleisch auch kühl zu halten und diese
temperatur keine rolle spielen und ein
anderer faktor ist dass es eben dort
auch zur bildung von aerosolen kommt
sohle das sind mini tröpfchen die fast
unsichtbaren stunden lang in der luft
schweben mit rauch simulieren etwa
forscher an der tu berlin
wie sich aerosolen ausbreiten und corona
viren in den räumen verteilen
das robert koch institut empfiehlt die
abstands und hygieneregeln weiter ernst
zu nehmen um die zahl der
neuansteckungen niedrig zu halten und
somit eine zweite große infektionswelle
zu verhindern
mit dem corona aus chor in gütersloh
beschäftigt sich auch unsere zdf spezial
direkt im anschluss an diese sendung und
dann schauen wir noch nach magdeburg
lange galt die stadt ja als corona frei
doch seit anfang juni sind die fälle
stark angestiegen
mehrere hundert menschen stehen in einem
wohnblock unter quarantäne
allein hier wurden 80 infizierte
bestätigt sie werden von den johannitern
mit lebensmitteln versorgt und jetzt der
blick nach südamerika wo die zahl der
korona infizierten weiter deutlich
steigt das land mit den zweitmeisten
fällen weltweit ist brasilien
dort gibt es mehr als eine million
infizierte anderes beispiel peru die
regierung dort hat schnell und
konsequent auf die pandemie reagiert
trotzdem gibt es eine viertelmillion
bestätigter fälle und mehr als 8000 tote
christoph röck hat berichtet der staubte
in der kalte winter von trägt zeigt
schon von weitem von der arbeit der
totengräber am stadtrand von lima direkt
hinter den armen vierteln kriegt ein
friedhof immer weiter über die hügel
getrieben von immer neuen toten
corona trifft auch in peru vor allem die
ärmsten
ich bin sicher er hätte die krankheit
besiegen können ich weiß nicht was sie
im krankenhaus mit ihm gemacht haben
misstrauen unsicherheit und frustration
gehen hand in hand mit dem tod in
führung
die wirtschaft bricht ein die schlechte
versorgungslage spart auch die
überforderten krankenhäuser nicht aus
ärzte demonstrieren für eine bessere
ausrüstung wir wollen unsere kinder
nicht als weisen unsere frauen nicht als
witwen zurücklassen wir brauchen
menschenwürdige arbeitsmöglichkeiten und
schutzausrüstung büro hat einen der
härtesten lockdown südamerikas verhängt
ausgangssperren die meisten geschäfte
und betriebe geschlossen
viele menschen sind auf sich allein
gestellt die staatliche hilfe reicht
nicht
sie helfen sich gegenseitig frühmorgens
tragen sie brennholz zusammen um zu
kochen
als kommunist gemeinschafts töpfe nennen
sie das viel zucker noch mehr
haferflocken etwas zimt ein süßer 3
der satz macht es gibt familien die vier
oder zehn kinder haben und keine arbeit
mehr
eine furchtbare situation der locker und
zeigt wirkung die zahl der
neuinfektionen beginnt zu sinken doch
gleichzeitig steigt der unmut im land
vom straßenhändler bis zum unternehmer
sie fordern die öffnung jetzt hat der
präsident eingelenkt seit anfang der
woche machen die ersten geschäfte wieder
auf früher als geplant eine gute und
eine schlechte nachricht hatten heute
die wirtschaftsweisen im gepäck die
schlechte zuerst ihrer prognose nach
wird die deutsche wirtschaft wegen der
korona krise noch stärker schrumpfen als
bislang gedacht nämlich voraussichtlich
um 6,5 prozent in diesem jahr so heftig
wie noch nie seit bestehen der
bundesrepublik
die gute nachricht unter anderem wegen
der lockerungen könnte sie sich schon ab
diesem sommer wieder erholen
auch der deutsche bildungsbericht wurde
heute vorgestellt und da gibt es
tendenzen die aufhorchen lassen
es gibt weniger mittlere abschlüsse und
weniger abiturienten so sank die quote
der jugendlichen mit abitur oder
fachhochschulreife sei 2014 von 53 auf
50 prozent im jahr 2018
zudem zeigt sich in der korona krise das
in sachen digitalisierung die schulen
nachsitzen müssen
susanne gelhard berichtet ihre
erfahrungen mit dem digitalen lernen in
corona zeiten
haben die zehnten klassen der igs in der
allem in einem projekt zusammen getragen
inklusive schüler um fragen wie es denn
so gelaufen ist
man hat sich selbst beibringen können
und wenn man jetzt die mutter zu hause
hat oder den vater ging es eigentlich
auch sehr gut klar mit den medien das
müsste übersichtlicher gestaltet werden
am anfang war es ja so dass wir über
verschiedene plattformen die aufgaben
bekommen
das war sehr unübersichtlich dann es ist
alles auf einer plattform die wut besser
digitale unterricht in deutschland noch
immer ein problem es mangelt an
ausstattung digitalen lehrplänen aus und
fortbildung von lehrkräften so vermerkt
ist der bildungsbericht der heute in
berlin vorgestellt wurde
das was eben bildungsbericht steht ist
natürlich ein weckruf ein weckruf an uns
alle an die schulträger die dafür
zuständig sind die schulen mit der
infrastruktur auszustatten die sie
brauchen um im digitalen zeitalter
lernen und lehren zu können
an der igs nieder olm stellen sie sich
auch künftig auf verstärkten digital
unterricht ein
jetzt gilt es alle schulen in
deutschland fit zu machen
es ist tatsächlich so dass wir keine
standards haben was die personelle und
materielle ausstattung von schulen
anbelangt das wäre aber notwendig um
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
herzustellen
corona offenbart die schwächen des
deutschen bildungssystems könnte aber
auch neue chancen eröffnen
und jetzt zu einer wichtigen
entscheidung für alle die facebook
nutzen
der bundesgerichtshof hat es dem
netzgiganten vorläufig verboten nahezu
unbegrenzt daten zu sammeln denn
facebooks ziel ist ja mit
maßgeschneiderter werbung geld zu
verdienen
mit jedem like den wir vergeben lernt
als der konzern besser kennen wie auch
über whats app instagram oder gefehlt
die ebenfalls dazu gehören kundendaten
sammeln auch der hauseigene virtual
reality brillenhersteller oculus und
business anwendungen wie workplace
zusätzlich werden daten auch mit
zahlreichen partnern getauscht so
erfährt der konzern etwa welche artikel
wir auf bestimmten medien seiten lesen
oder was wir im internet kaufen und
vervollständigt so das bild das er von
uns hat alles transparent sagt facebook
denn das stehe auch in den
nutzungsbedingungen christian decker und
birgit franke berichten china lang ist
jura studentin in passau nutzt dienste
wie whatsapp facebook und instagram seit
ihrem studium beschäftigt sie sich auch
mit dem datenschutz ärgert sich über die
vorgehensweise von facebook ich weiß im
grunde nicht bescheid welche daten sie
haben oder an wen diese daten eigentlich
weitergegeben wurden
der nutzer weiß im grunde nichts der
bundesgerichtshof hat heute in einem
rechtsverfahren vorerst entschieden dass
facebook als marktführer die umfassende
sammlung von daten seiner nutzer
überarbeiten muss denn wir haben im
ergebnis auch keine ernsthaften zweifel
dass facebook die marktbeherrschende
stellung missbräuchlich ausnutzt
das gericht fordert angesichts der
marktbeherrschenden stellung eine
einwilligung der nutzer bezogen auf alle
dienste von facebook momentan haben die
nutzer aber keine wahlmöglichkeit
facebook will jetzt reagieren ganz
konkret wenn wir uns jetzt mit dem
bundeskartellamt zusammen setzen an
einem umsetzungsplan arbeiten und haben
für diesen und für die umsetzung 14
monate zeit das bundeskartellamt dass
das verbot ausgesprochen hat hält die
entscheidung für zukunftsweisend das war
kern unserer entscheidung dass der
nutzer in diese uferlose verarbeitung
nicht mehr einwilligen muss und das ist
das was der bundesgerichtshof heute
tatsächlich bestätigt hat für tina lang
und für viele weitere nutzer der
facebook dienste ist es ein etappensieg
im kampf gegen die datensammelei
bundesinnenminister seehofer hat die
rechtsextreme vereinigung nord adler
verboten
am morgen gab es razzien gegen
führungsmitglieder in mehreren
bundesländern
die gruppierung verfolgt laut
bundesinnenministerium eine
nationalsozialistische ideologie sie
tritt auch unter anderem namen wie
völkische renaissance auf und ist vor
allem im netz aktiv die kollegen von zdf
heute haben die gruppen seit monaten
beobachtet in der zdf- heute- app finden
sie zahlreiche chat brutto
kolle und dokumente aus der recherche
und dazu einschätzungen von extremismus
forschern im bilanzskandal beim
dax-konzern wirecard ist der frühere
chef markus braun gestern abend
vorübergehend festgenommen worden
gegen eine millionen kaution kommt er
wieder frei die untersuchungshaft werde
gegen zahlung von fünf millionen euro
ausgesetzt teilte die staatsanwaltschaft
münchen mit
brown wird vorgeworfen den umsatz des
unternehmens durch vorgetäuschte
einnahmen aufgebläht zu haben wirecard
hatte anfang der woche eingeräumt dass
angebliche bankguthaben in
milliarden-höhe wohl nicht existieren in
der korona krise zieht der lufthansa
konzern weitere konsequenzen und
schließt den betrieb des ferienfliegers
sunexpress deutschland betroffen sind
rund 1200 mitarbeiter die verbleibenden
flüge sollen von der türkischen
schwestergesellschaft euro wings und
anderen airlines abgewickelt werden
kunden würden automatisch umgebucht
beide freiwilligen feuerwehr als schöffe
bei gericht oder in der flüchtlingshilfe
viele millionen deutsche engagieren sich
ehrenamtlich allerdings nicht überall
gleich in etlichen regionen sieht es
weniger gut aus mit der
bürgerschaftlichen arbeit ändern will
dass die heute gegründete bundesstiftung
für engagement und ehrenamt mit sitz in
neustrelitz in mecklenburg vorpommern
alle stadt fällt nicht immer leicht ist
die arbeit mit schwerem gerät für ina
marie wittkopf
dafür ist die 16-jährige mit
leidenschaft dabei
beim thw in gadebusch absolviert sie
ehrenamtlich die sechsmonatige
grundausbildung diese zusammenarbeit im
team
man kommt unser leute man lernt was und
ich finde es einfach toll dass man auf
das ernst machen kann
35 mitglieder hat der kleine ortsverband
mindestens 50 bräuchte er gerade der
nachwuchs fehlt und da ist für uns
natürlich jede hilfe willkommen die uns
eben gerade bei der helfer werbung
helfer bindung unterstützt genau diese
hilfe wäre jetzt die deutsche stiftung
für engagement und ehrenamt spielten der
festakt zur gründung heute nachmittag im
mecklenburgischen neustrelitz
hier wird die bundesstiftung ihren sitz
haben im renovierten carolinen palais
von strelitz wird mit diesem signal dass
wir die bundesregierung hier eindeutig
sendet an dass irland tatsächlich so
weit wollten die republik strahlen und
wird lebensverhältnisse in ost und west
zum thema machen
gerade mal neun prozent der
bundesstiftung anliegen in
ostdeutschland die institution nach
neustrelitz zu geben ein zeichen an die
ostdeutschen länder weil wir mit dieser
stiftung bundesweit bedeutung bekommen
mit 75 arbeitsplätzen und es auch ein
zeichen ist dass wir mal im land in
ostdeutschland dinge neu ansiedeln 30
millionen deutsche sind wie ina marie
wittkopf ehrenamtlich tätig mit hilfe
der stiftung sollen es noch deutlich
mehr werden
die neue corona waren app entwickelt
sich zu einem echten erfolg mehr als
zwölf millionen mal wurde sie schon
runtergeladen dabei ist sie gerade erst
seit einer woche zu haben etwa 80
prozent der rund 58 millionen smartphone
nutzer in deutschland sollen die app
installieren können die politik hofft
hier noch auf nachbesserungen damit die
app auch auf älteren modellen
funktioniert ja und nun zum sport und
sylvia norbert und da sorgt ein höchst
umstrittenes tennisturnier weiter für
auf allerdings die adria tour
organisiert von serbischen tennis star
novak djokovic
laxey gene und sicherheitsregeln in
corona zeiten drei spieler hatten sich
mit dem virus infiziert heute gab
djokovic bekannt auch ich bin positiv
getestet worden
weltweit sorgt eher leicht sind auf der
kreatur für unverständnis besonders in
tennis kreisen
nun ist er im zentrum der kritik
stehende organisator bereits der vierte
infizierte spieler novak djokovic gab
heute auf seiner website bekannt dass er
und seine frau elena in belgrad positiv
auf corona getestet wurden bisher ohne
symptome
ihre beiden kinder seien nicht betroffen
volle tribünen mangelhafte hygiene
maßnahmen und ungezügelter kontakt zu
fans haben empörung hervorgerufen
turnierteilnehmer alexander zverev ist
nach eigenen angaben negativ getestet
novak djokovic bedauert in seinem
statement die infektionsfälle und drückt
seine hoffnung aus dass es allen gut
gehe
die fortsetzung der adria tour in banja
luka und sarajevo wurde heute abgesagt
zur premier league liverpools
meisterschaft zum greifen da trainer
klopp schaute gestern abend auf
verfolger manchester city der sein
heimspiel souverän gewann und lehrer
sein der war nach fast einem jahr
verletzungspause auch wieder mit dabei
ein wechsel um 323 tage nach seinem
kreuzbandriss im rechten knie ein
besonderer moment für lina saneh der auf
der wunschliste des fc bayern steht
zunächst aber sorgt eine offensichtlich
rassistisch motivierte aktion für
entsetzen ein flugzeug kreist über dem
stadion nur das leben weiter zähle so
die botschaft auf dem banner der fc
burnley distanziert sich umgehend
inzwischen ermittelt die polizei
sportlich ist es ein unbeschwerter abend
für manchester city englands meister
gewinnt locker 5 zu 0 gegen burnley das
team von pep guardiola tut sich im
ersten spiel nach der korona pause
wesentlich leichter als jugendclubs
liverpool beim 0 0 gestern spielt
manchester auch übermorgen ähnlich
erfolgreich und gewinnt gegen chelsea
hätten sie liverpools vorzeitige
meisterschaft zumindest um eine woche
aufgeschoben
das wars auch hier haben die banken
ordert morgen wird es wieder heiß und
sonnig die details erfahren sie gleich
beim bäcker von essent elli so viel von
uns schön dass sie dabei war das heute
journal mit christian sievers heute
gegen 10 vor 10
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr jetzt geht's hier weiter
mit dem zdf spezial einen sonnigen abend
wünscht dass heute teams
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter fast wolkenlos ist
derzeit über deutschland aber auch nur
fast denn dieses kleine tief hier
das bringt durchaus einige wolken in den
osten deutschlands allerdings sorgt das
hoch für erwärmung außerdem kommt noch
warme luft aus dem südwesten zu uns
schauen wir in die nacht da wird es
wolkenlos seien meist sternenklar
die temperaturen sinken auf 15 grad am
niederrhein und 7 grad im vogtland es
wird also noch einmal kühlen lüften sie
nochmal gut die wohnung durch denn in
den nächsten tagen wird es heiss morgen
tagesverlauf dann im westen viel
sonnenschein und auch nach süden im
osten allerdings hier zwischen oder und
neiße da kommen wolken mit dem kleinen
tief an aber es bleibt trocken die
temperaturen steigen dabei auf 30 grad
am niederrhein und am oberrhein 22 grad
sind zum vogtland aber fast überall
gehen die werte über die 25 grad marke
die nächsten tage am donnerstag gibt es
schauer und gewitter die von osten her
aufziehen sonst ist es sonnig werte bis
31 grad ja und am freitag dann bis 32
grad nur einzelne gewitter die gewitter
am samstag werden allerdings dann
unwetterartig werte bis 33 grad
ein schöner abend